if you've been playing Animal Crossing
you've probably upgraded your house a
few times and unlocked bridges and
slopes but all of those modifications
are going to cost you a lot
here are three methods that can make you
a millionaire and Animal Crossing new
horizons peacock butterflies so the idea
behind this method is to get lots of
peacock butterflies to spawn on your
Island and sell them to Timmy and Tommy
they sell for 2500 bells apiece or for
3752 Flik if you've been playing New
Horizons for a while and you haven't
seen peacock butterflies that's because
you don't have any black blue or purple
flowers on your Island I have been using
black tulips which you can get by
crossbreeding to red tulips but any dark
flower will do once you've grown a few
dark flowers start putting together
flower patches in close vicinity within
a couple minutes you should start seeing
peacock butterfly spawn and the more
flowers you have on your Island the more
will show up now I will admit I don't
have the best setup here a lot of my
flower patches are far apart and
separated by rivers due to construction
but if you have a good number of patches
set up near each other you should be
able to fill your pockets with these
butterflies fairly quickly one thing I
should point out is that peacock
butterflies aren't available all year
and you can only catch them during the
day so if you're trying to catch them
early in the morning or late at night
you'll just be wasting your time
tarantula island you've probably heard
of tarantula island by now if you
haven't the concept is simple head to a
deserted island after 7:00 p.m. pick all
the weeds pick all the flowers cut down
the trees into sterile the rocks for
good measure then dump all your
resources you've collected on the beach
once you've dismantled the poor island
tarantulas should start spawning every
few minutes the idea behind this method
is that by clearing everything off the
island bugs that would normally spawn on
trees or buy flowers can't this means
that only tarantulas can spawn once
you've filled your pockets with
tarantulas a terrifying thought I know
head back to your island and sell them
to Timmy and Tommy for eight thousand
each or if you're lucky to flick for
twelve thousand the stock market the
mantra you got to spend money to make
money is also true in Animal Crossing
the stock market is one of the best but
also riskiest ways to accrue a small
fortune in Animal Crossing New Horizons
every Sunday until noon Daisy May will
visit your Island and sell you turnips
her prices usually hover around a
hundred bells for 10 turnips if you find
her prices reasonable you want to buy as
many turnips as you possibly can and
wait every day once in the morning and
once in the afternoon
check with Timmy and Tommy to see how
much they are buying turnips for their
prices usually follow one of a few
patterns either they'll start low and
spike towards the middle or end of the
week they'll keep dropping all week with
no increase or they'll be totally random
for the spike patterns they'll start by
dropping price by a few bells each time
and then you'll see a big increase
followed by at least one more increased
price at which point you should sell if
your prices don't follow this trend then
you probably have one of the worst price
patterns obviously the goal here is to
make a bit of a profit so it's a good
idea to check your friends prices if
yours aren't looking good
in fact I'd check with them as often as
possible who knows their town might be
buying turnips for a lot of bells these
are some of the most efficient ways to
earn lots of money we found in Animal
Crossing new horizons to maximize your
profit we recommend mixing and matching
these strategies and if you have a
method or two you'd like to share please
leave it in the comments below and be
sure to check out our other Animal
Crossing videos here on YouTube
thank you so much for watching
[Music]